[Music]
now lately there's been a phrase that
news organizations have been throwing
around a lot critical race theory
everyone is saying it but no one seems
to be able to agree on what it
is now how do we get to a point where
everyone is saying a phrase they can't
even define
let's find out in a segment called how
did we get here
in the past few weeks several state
legislatures have introduced bills
banning critical race
theory they've done it in georgia
tennessee florida
mississippi oklahoma and a bunch of
other states where you can buy
confederate flags at gas stations but
the thing is while some americans are
furious about critical race theory
a lot of people don't even know what it
is and i don't blame them
critical race theory sounds like the
subtitle of a book called mario kart for
dummies
first i'm going to pick up speed then
i'm going to throw some nana's then i'm
going to get some
coins and that is my critical race
theory
now in order to talk about critical race
theory we're going to start with
something called the 1619 project
the 1619 project is an extraordinary
pulitzer prize winning work of
journalism conceived of by a reporter
named
nicole hannah jones it was released
to commemorate the 400th anniversary of
the arrival
of enslaved africans in the colonies
that would become america
that's right the first anniversary is
paper the fifth is wood and the 400th
is well researched and award-winning
journalism get to work husbands
one of the reasons the 1619 project has
been so controversial
is that it proposes that we should talk
a lot more about the consequences of
slavery
and the contributions of black people
when we talk about the foundations of
our country
which of course means acknowledging that
racism permeates our history
because the fact is right now kids
aren't learning the realities of our
history
in 2018 only eight percent of u.s
high school seniors could identify
slavery as the central cause of the
civil war
and that is horrifying that's like only
eight percent of kids knowing you can
make a volcano with mentos and diet coke
they're both basic facts now the good
news is
that about two-thirds of students do
seem to know that the emancipation
proclamation freed the slaves except
and here's the thing it absolutely did
not do that
that required a whole constitutional
amendment which wasn't even ratified
till after abraham lincoln died
in a horrible boating accident
all the 1619 project was supposed to do
is help teach students about the role
slavery has played in american history
now some people claim that's rewriting
history and maybe it is but
shouldn't we revise things when we get
better information
we used to prescribe cocaine for
toothaches now we know better
and it's mostly used so that former
lacrosse players can talk about crypto
for seven hours straight
yeah you gotta have bitcoin bro
the point is as we learn more of course
we should adjust what we're teaching
in some parts of the country if students
learn black history at all
they learn that most masters treated
their slaves kindly or
slaves were given the opportunity to
become christians instead of remaining
heathen
or that slaves got to eat all the
barbecue pringles they wanted
all of those things are equal parts
[ __ ] but the first two are
actual quotes from a textbook that was
used in south carolina
for 130 years which is probably why
their current senator thinks that racism
doesn't exist
he thinks it disappeared right around
when daniel boone killed all the
dinosaurs
now this would be a great time for me to
tell you what we need to do to improve
our national history curriculum but
here's the thing we don't have a
national history
curriculum every state sets its own
teaching standards
think of school curriculums like state
mottos
every state has a different one and some
of them are batshit
crazy oregon's state motto is she flies
with her own wings
that's not a motto that's a tagline for
a cicada biopic
the fact is most states don't mandate a
specific amount of black history at all
which is why most white people only know
about harriet tubman
martin luther king and barack obama even
worse
20 of them think that that's destiny's
child
if only there were some kind of say
prize-winning black history curriculum
developed by some of the greatest
scholars in the country
i'm sure that americans would welcome it
with open arms
and by arms i mean guns because it turns
out there are a lot of white people who
really don't want to learn the truth
about america and that finally brings us
back to
critical race theory which is just a way
of examining society and history without
pretending that racism doesn't exist
racism is part of our past and our
present it's been with us for 400 years
you can't squash it into two sentences
in a textbook
between the civil war and the roaring
20s you shouldn't fix
history to make you feel better learning
about slavery feels awful
too bad try living with its
repercussions while white people tell
you there weren't any
also it should make you feel bad it
should make you feel so bad that you
make sure
nothing like it ever happens again
critical race theory gives us the tools
to examine our history
in an open and honest way and to fix the
parts of our educational system that
aren't doing that
but my theory is that some white people
don't want to change our education
system because it benefits them
they literally were able to become
congressmen and senators and
people who make laws about american
history without actually knowing
american history
or maybe they're afraid that we might
start treating white people like white
people treat
us maybe they don't even know they've
been learning the white version of
history this whole time
anyway that's my theory and if it's not
accurate
my theory about race will fall apart as
soon as someone critically examines it
if only there is a way to do that but i
guess that's how we got here
[Music]
you